the Joe Rogan experience I mean Tulsi
and Bernie are the only candidates worth
giving a [ __ ] about I thought dude that
[ __ ] Town Hall sunk this is how many
candidates are there now I feel like two
other ones just jumped in the race now
we have like I don't [ __ ] know their
names he's too close to beta it's too
close does look like he would be called
that but his dad actually just openly
said in in interviews like yeah I called
him beta because I wanted him to get the
Mexican vote because I knew he would
eventually run for office what his real
names like Robert Oh Robert oh Christ
that sounds like people I mean these
people are like a hundred shades of
Hillary I mean every single one of them
other than Tulsi and Bernie just seem
like they're just like Hillary Clinton
light well they've also done this weird
thing where they're like no straight
white men like okay like there's like
straight white men we're not voting for
straight white men okay that's just as
bad as saying you're never voting for a
woman that's just as bad as saying
you're never voting for a black person
you mean I get it there's been a lot of
straight white men they've been present
I get it right you're right but to say
no straight like to disqualify someone
based on something they have no control
over whatsoever is a form of
discrimination I know you don't think
it's a form of discrimination because so
many of these people have already had
that job I get it it seems unfair you're
right but you can't say that because
that's a shitty way of thinking it's
it's piss-poor logic and thinking it's
discriminatory identity politics yes it
reigned supreme and I thought there was
like a combatting supporters from Kamala
Harris and Bernie at some rally or
something and then they just kept
shouting we need a woman president it's
like that that's like the only reason
why you like Kamala Harris you know I
mean Kamala Harris I've saw this one
speech that she was giving when she was
talking about forcing children to attend
school by holding their parents
accountable where she instituted a pile
if the kids miss school the parents
could be arrested do you know about that
now it was soup that is their brain it
was super disturbing and she was talking
about how effective it was and that you
know they had cops show up at the door
of the the woman's house who was a
single mom who had these children the
kids weren't going to school like hey no
she was a cop I mean it's a top cop
exactly but that authoritative
authoritarian nonsense like that way of
thinking you know why you do that cuz no
one's ever done that to you right
something even knocked on your [ __ ]
door and said hey we're gonna lock you
up in jail because you're 16 year-old
boy when you have three kids right and
if you're a single mom anyone who's a
single mom who has a boy knows and that
[ __ ] boy hits puberty if they run
with the wrong crowd good [ __ ] luck
trying to control them good luck is it
hard
yeah real hard and if she's got a job or
two jobs maybe cuz she's trying to put
food on the table and keep the [ __ ]
lights on and you're gonna arrest her
cuz her kid doesn't show up at school
holy [ __ ] can you imagine looking at all
the problems in our country and being
like you know what we need to arrest
parents if their kids are truant yeah
it's it's insane I mean make sure I'm
99% sure correct about they're talking
about her like regret about this policy
and yes I wonder why she's running for
[ __ ] president you should regret
something you want to hear another
annual policy going back to Robert or
roar it is the human cost of c'mon I got
more on truancy the progressive
prosecutor wanted to transform how
California responded the students
missing school parents like I'm her
surname Cherie Cherie people's wound up
paying the price so she this lady I read
that I remember reading this wound up
going to jail yeah so yeah and there was
a good reason her kid was sick or
something she
[Applause]